Merry Christmas it's time to rename
Uranus the seventh planet from the sun
has an absolutely ridiculous name your
anus come on even if you try to avoid
calling it Uranus by pronouncing it
Uranus you still have to say urine and
everyone knows you mean your anus why
are you not saying it why are you afraid
of Uranus personally I think we should
change its name by simply fixing the
fact that Uranus is the only planet
besides Earth in our solar system whose
name comes from Greek mythology not
Roman mythology let's give Uranus its
Roman name kyus we could also rename
Earth Tellus or terara but at least
Earth doesn't sound like a bee hole kyus
was the father of Saturn who was the
father of Jupiter it's perfect I love it
and this is not a joke okay this is a
serious request from me to the
astronomical authorities reject your
anus Embrace
kyus
please